if you followed my PhD journey starting
in 2013 and finishing in December 2018
then you'll have seen what I have been
studying you've seen how I have studied
it but I want to in this video
definitively set out what I found and
what ended up going in my thesis and
thanks to dashlane for sponsoring this
video it's going to go into some detail
so to stop people from feeling lost I've
broken it down into sections let's start
with some background so my PhD was about
the Earth's atmosphere like ogres like
onions the atmosphere is divided into
layers from the bottom up
you have the troposphere the
stratosphere the meter sphere and the
thermosphere these layers are most
commonly defined by their temperature
profile how temperature changes as you
go higher up in the troposphere the
temperature gets colder the higher you
go if you've ever been up a mountain
you'll have felt this effect however
once you go past about 10 kilometers
above the surface the temperature stays
the same and then actually increases
with altitude this happens until you hit
about 50 kilometers up at which point
the temperature starts to decrease with
altitude again this region is called the
stratosphere and it behaves very
differently to our layer the atmosphere
the troposphere the largest feature of
the stratosphere is the polar vortex a
circulation of fast-moving air over a
thousand kilometers across with wind
speeds of over 200 kilometres per hour
that forms every year in the winter over
the Arctic my PhD was about how these
two layers interact with one another in
particular during big violent events
called sudden stratospheric warming a
sudden stratospheric warming occurs when
the polar vortex breaks apart either
because it splits in two or because it
moved too far south these events are
called warming's because when the vortex
breaks apart air from further south
piles into the stratospheric Arctic and
squishes it down this squashing or more
properly adiabatic descent results in
increases in temperatures of up to 70 or
even 80 degrees Celsius in the
stratosphere over just a couple of days
and we've known since about the year
2000 that when sudden stratospheric
warming happen the weather in the
troposphere is affected thorpe up to 2
storms going across the Atlantic track
further south than normal and there's an
increased chance of extreme cold in the
mid-latitudes this happens because the
primary mode of variability in the
stratosphere is the strength of the
polar vortex or the primary mode of
variability in the troposphere is the
location of the jet stream the
fast-moving river of air that divides
cold arctic air from warmer mid-latitude
air and these two modes of variability
are couples together which we can
describe mathematically by an Arctic
Oscillation index which is just a number
which can be defined at any height above
the surface if the AO index is positive
the polar vortex is strong and the jet
stream is relatively straight and far
north
if the AO index is negative then the
vortex is weak and the jet stream is
wavy and further south in the aftermath
of sudden stratospheric warming we see
descending negative AO index anomalies
the influence of the sudden warming
creeping towards the surface and staying
there so a vortex breaking apart results
in a very wavy jet stream which sits
further south we know that this happens
but we don't know how this happens my
PhD was about proposing a quantitative
mechanism for this descending influence
and in order to explain exactly how I
did that I first need to give you two
more pieces of specific background
information the Arctic Oscillation index
is a result of a complex statistical
process called principal component
analysis or PCA you don't need to
understand how this works but the end
result is important when applied to
surface pressures over the northern
hemisphere over a couple of years of
data pca defines a pattern over the
earth
this pattern explains whether majority
of variability in surface pressure takes
place for example it shows that if
pressure over the Arctic is relatively
high the pressure over the North
Atlantic is relatively low a bit like a
seesaw this is the Arctic Oscillation
pattern and the a/o index is the number
that tells you if the seesaw has one end
up or the other in terms of the pattern
whether the Arctic pressure is high and
so atlantic pressure is low or if the
Arctic pressure is low and the Atlantic
pressure
hi the first step of my PhD was
simplifying how we represent these
variations in surface pressure for
reasons that will become clear in a
second I was specifically interested in
the pressure over the Arctic
so I defined a new pressure index
designed to be equivalent to the AO
index it was designed to be simple to
bank
you just averaged the pressure over the
area north of the 65 north latitude line
and then subtracts the long running
average to produce a pressure anomaly
over the Arctic but is this equivalent
to the AO index well if you compare the
Arctic Oscillation pattern to where my
index is calculated you see that my
index is defined over the same area as
the primary blob of the AO pattern and
because the AO is a seesaw pattern if
you know whether one side of the seesaw
is up or down you know if the other side
is down or up so my index contains the
same information as the AO index but in
a simpler way and this is something
which I demonstrated statistically so I
defined a new index to represent the
principal mode of variability of air
pressure but why was that important to
do well I defined the index in such a
way that I could easily derive equations
that govern how it varied in response to
changes in the rest of the atmosphere so
remember what I was trying to do I was
trying to show how the strength of the
polar vortex varying could change the
position of the jet stream in the
troposphere if I could derive a set of
equations which showed how the pressure
index in the troposphere varied in
response to changes in the stratosphere
then I will have achieved that you can
think of my index as like an imaginary
cylinder of air surrounding and above
the Arctic the pressure anomaly in a
particular slice of this cylinder has
the same information in it as the
complex pca created AO index but while
that index has lots of things that
influence how it changes in time my
pressure index has just two things the
mass of air that goes through the
cylinders walls above the slice and the
mass of air that moves vertically
through the slice if air moves
horizontally into the cylinder above
then there will be more mass
on top of the slice of cylinder which
will increase the pressure on it
likewise if air moves vertically up
through the cylinder then the pressure
on the slice will also increase what I
needed to do then was derive two
equations one that describes the air
mass that moves horizontally into the
cylinder and one that describes the mass
that moves vertically in the cylinder
these are those two equations and they
were the next important thing I did in
my PhD if you want details of how
they're derived then read my thesis link
in the description for this video I need
to explain the most important variable
in these equations sign the stream
function a stream function is a way that
we can mathematically describe a fluid
flow the atmosphere behaves like a fluid
on a rotating sphere and so we can
define a stream function for the
atmosphere a stream function is a scalar
field meaning that it has a single value
at every point in the atmosphere the
speed that the atmosphere flows in the
east to west and north to south
directions otherwise known as wind is
calculated by looking at how much the
stream function varies in the north to
south and east to west directions
respectively you can also calculate the
temperature of the atmosphere at a point
by looking at how much the stream
function changes as you get higher in
the atmosphere so by calculating the
gradient of one field the stream
function you get information about
multiple fields wind and temperature I
used a stream function to calculate the
air mass moving in to and within the
imaginary cylinder of air around the
Arctic via these two equations but I've
only told you what the stream function
is not how you calculate it and that's
really a video all on its own but
basically you use a variable called
potential vorticity or PV for short
which might sound familiar to long-term
viewers
Peevy is another scalar variable that's
rich in information about the state of
the atmosphere it's not a physical thing
that you can see or feel but constructed
from hell air rotates and how
temperature changes with height via a
process called inversion you can take a
PV distribution and get a stream
function from it the PV can be just one
part of the atmosphere and yet the
stream function you get by inverting it
is defined everywhere so the stream
function associated with a PV
distribution in just one area encodes
information about how that area
influences the rest of the atmosphere
this has been a few conceptual leaps one
after the other
so just to recap PV is a variable in the
atmosphere which you invert to get a
stream function which describes how the
atmosphere behaves the stream function
can be used to calculate how air mass
gets moved around in the Arctic and
those mass fluxes used to calculate
changes in my pressure index PV
calculates a stream function which
calculates mass fluxes which calculates
changes in the pressure index which
tells us whether the surface atmospheric
seesaw is up or down if I could show
that changes in the PV distribution in
the stratosphere caused changes in the
pressure index at the surface then I
will have achieved my goal but I found
something a bit different and not what I
expected you can add together the stream
functions calculated from inverting
different PV distributions in different
places in isolation to get a total
stream function if you've studied
electrostatics this will sound familiar
it's just like the superposition of
charges and remember that PV encodes
information about the area of the
atmosphere it's defined in transmitted
by the stream function to the whole
atmosphere so if you invert the PV in
the stratosphere on its own you will get
a stream function which tells you how
the stratosphere influences the rest of
the atmosphere I could define a stream
function sy s which only has
stratospheric information in it it's
calculated by inverting stratospheric PV
only
and then use this stream function in my
horizontal and vertical mass flux
equations to see how the stratosphere
influences the pressure index in the
troposphere and I could equally define a
stream function sy T which is calculated
by inverting P V from the troposphere on
its own and then use that in my mass
flux equations combining the two stream
functions together produces the total
stream function and so the total
horizontal and vertical mass flux
however by considering the stream
functions separately you can isolate how
much horizontal and how much vertical
mass flux is forced by changes in the
stratosphere and how much is forced by
changes in the troposphere my theory was
that in the aftermath of sudden
stratospheric warming the vortex
splitting apart but the stratosphere had
a strong influence on the troposphere
communicated via mass fluxes induced by
changes in the stratospheric PV
distribution man it literally took this
entire video up until that point to be
able to say that sentence and have you
understand what it means I could test my
theory by calculating the total mass
fluxes moving in to and within the
imaginary Arctic cylinder of air via my
equations and then comparing that to the
mass flux is seen in observations if the
total mass flux predicted by my
equations matched those seen in
observations then that would verify that
my equations were correct and if that
was the case the relative sizes of the
two contributions from the stratosphere
and from the troposphere will tell me if
the stratosphere has a significant
influence on the troposphere so was I
right this is an example time series of
my pressure index as seen in
observations the horizontal axis is time
and the vertical axis is height above
the ground you see the sending positive
and negative pressure anomalies over the
Arctic now compare this to what I
calculated using my equations at first
glance they don't appear very similar
but you start to see similarities
between the two
this large negative feature followed by
an ascending positive anomaly this large
positive anomaly encompassing a negative
anomaly
all of which are approximately the right
magnitude if you do the stats the two
time series from observations and
calculated by equations are reasonably
close to one another for the past 40
years of data they correlate moderately
I'll spare you the exact details of why
this doesn't work perfectly but the
basic reason is that you're trying to
sum up lots of things which are positive
and negative to try and make something
which is very nearly zero and that's
open to a lot of errors especially when
using course resolution data if you're
willing to accept that these two are
close enough to one another then you can
examine the contributions from the
stratosphere on its own and from the
troposphere on its own clearly the
influence of the stratosphere doesn't
really get past the tropopause the
barrier between the troposphere and the
stratosphere but this is cool eagle-eyed
viewers will have noticed that something
is missing take another look at these
two equations for the horizontal and
vertical mass flux the vertical mass
flux equation is a linear function of
the stream function used meaning that
the stream function never gets
multiplied by itself a bunch of stuff
happens to it but it only appears once
the horizontal mass flux equation
however isn't linear it has a sy times
si here it's a nonlinear equation in sy
that means that while you can add
together the vertical mass flux
contribution from the stratosphere and
the vertical mass flux contribution from
the troposphere to get a total you can't
do that for the horizontal mass flux to
get the total contribution you add up
the contributions from the stratosphere
and the troposphere and then add an
interference term which has both
stratospheric and tropospheric
information in it so just to reiterate
because this equation is nonlinear when
combining contributions from two
different stream functions you have to
add an interference term to the Sun
representing the interaction of those
two stream functions if you add that
interference term to the stratospheric
influence represented using sy s star
then you see the influence of the
stratosphere penetrating into the Trop
fear or in other words the nonlinear
interaction of stratospheric and
tropospheric information allows for
changes in the stratosphere to affect
the surface and while this is just one
example time series the overall
statistics for the 40 years of data back
up this conclusion
so speaking mathematically I
demonstrated that the nonlinear
interaction of stratospheric and
tropospheric information substantially
forced arctic pressure tendencies in the
troposphere which is equivalent to
saying that they substantially forced
the AO index in the troposphere or
surface weather and that's not something
which we known before and it was
something which is only possible to
learn because of the entire framework
that I'd constructed in my thesis from
the pressure index to the mass flux
equations I realized that this video is
a relatively deep dive with lots of new
concepts and not very much time so in
case you got lost along the way let me
rephrase what I learned my PhD without
referencing any of the maths I learned
that the stratosphere that's the next
layer up of the atmosphere can influence
the troposphere our layer the atmosphere
including weather at the surface but not
directly instead the stratosphere
influences surface weather by the way
that it communicates with the
troposphere or if you like but the
stratosphere can influence the surface
weather but if and only if the
troposphere is in the right
configuration to receive that influence
this is a relationship which is most
noticeable in the aftermath of big
events like southern stratospheric
warming but it holds generally and that
nonlinear relationship the conversation
that goes on between the stratosphere in
the troposphere
is something that we didn't
quantitatively know until my PhD this
video as long as it is is still only a
brief overview of what I did in my PhD
and it doesn't even include all the
results from my thesis so if you'd like
to learn more about what I did and read
it yourself then I don't recommend
giving the background chapter a read
then you can do so on my website I have
a website by the way my website is
actually protected by this video sponsor
dashlane I started using dashlane a
couple of weeks ago on my phone and on
my computer and my laptop and honestly I
have nothing but positive things to say
about it - Lane is a service that keeps
track of your passwords behind painted
security software so that only you not
even they have access to your encrypted
data but more than that it alerts you if
you reuse passwords which I had about
150 times and can generate and
automatically store strong passwords for
you so since starting to use the service
a couple of weeks ago every single one
of my online accounts has become safer
and given that the app on your phone
actually auto fills forms out for you as
long as you've got your master password
it makes life easier - frankly for the
amount of my life that I spend online I
think it's worth spending a little bit
of money a month to make sure that my
information from my social media
accounts to my youtube channel to my
bank details as safe and if you think so
- then go to - Lane comm forward slash
Simon Clark and if you'd like to upgrade
to premium then the first 200 people to
use the promo code Simon Clarke will get
10% off thank you for watching the video
I hope that you learned a few things and
I didn't make this either too simple or
too complicated there knowing me I
probably managed to do both if you'd
like to see the tropospheric effect on a
sudden stratospheric warming then go and
check out the video I made on the recent
cold snap across North America and if
you haven't seen my PhD vlogs then go
watch them thank you very much for
watching the video and I'll see you in
the next one
you